hello my name is mike lodes and today
i'm going to be taking a look at how
medieval weapons and
armor are portrayed in video games
[Music]
video games i'm going to take a look at
today are
kingdom come the witcher 4
honor mordau chivalry dark souls
and mountain blade let's take a look at
how
swords are used in video games forging a
sword
kingdom come deliverance do it
so what we see in this clip is the
finishing stages
the blade has already been made
but what i like about this clip is these
people
clearly are taking care you know what
you're doing
high status swords they were made by
alchemy it's an incredibly
sophisticated process give it here
and we'll put it all together
where it goes slightly wrong is where
he's putting the grip on at the end
although it's true that you would heat
the tang that's the little bit that
comes up
from the blade for the grip to go on
what they're doing there is they've
heated half the blade all that
art all that care to get the proper
spring temper
will have been lost
because they've heated it up and thrown
it away
and the other little technical problem
is when they put the pommel on that's
the
bit that balances a sword at the end
when they put that
on they just plop it on
well the the tang that should come
through the pommel so there's a little
bit sticking up
and then you hammer that over and
splay it out peen it out rivet it out
and that's
what holds everything secure and
together this pommel would have fallen
off as soon as they picked it up so
little details are wrong but the feel of
the thing is great
it's magnificent one-handed versus
two-handed use of the sword
dark souls if you tap y when you're in a
situation like this when you have a
one-handed sword and a shield
you switch to two-handed but blocking
with the sword
doesn't really block they kind of
completely misunderstand
how swords are used it doesn't block 100
of the damage
that's just wrong putting two hands on
will give you a more powerful stroke
it does not in any way hinder your
ability to defend with a sword
when you're using a single-handed an
arming sword with one hand and then
clearly you're always going to favor
your dominant arm because mostly that's
going to be the stronger arm
pens i know but mightier than the sword
you don't
ever block with a sword
that's not how it's done i'm using a
flat i knock it aside
i'm keeping a flow so this idea of
square blocking
it may be easier for game developers to
create that kind of action
but it's not how it was done
single-edged swords versus double-edged
swords
for honor
well you know the first thing i've got
to say about that clip
is how good i thought the action was
i mean the armor was distracting because
it's so fantastically
wrong but the body shapes the movements
the positions they got in
that was good it had quality there
the advantage of a two-edged sword is if
one edge is getting a little dull
you can turn it around and you've got a
second edge to use so it can be a
considerable
advantage on the battlefield that you're
keeping one edge sharp
the advantage of a single edge sword is
usually that it's less expensive because
you don't have to have
such a sophisticated temper
that is authentic as long as you're
gripping tight enough
the sword won't move and if it doesn't
move
it won't cut you so
this person is not able to pull it
through this person's hand
because this person has taken it and
they've turned it into a lever action
removing the sword from their hand so
those kind of
blade grabbing disarms are authentic
and they are possible but they require
skill
and knowledge and do not try this at
home
throwing a sword moored howl
[Music]
swords are extremely versatile weapons
that's one of their advantages you can
use them in all sorts of different ways
a powerful man with a powerful thrust
delivering a thrust to somebody's chest
could almost stop a heart
you can use it as a lever to unbalance
your opponent you've got that great
heavy pommel that great metal weight on
the end and you can have deflected the
sword and used the pommel to smash
and punch why
why would you throw it it is so
stupid to throw away
a weapon and it's not even the person
has lots of other weapons
i just can't get my head around the idea
of somebody throwing
a sword decapitation
chivalry two
so what we see here is clearly supposed
to be a
european medieval battlefield and so in
that context
you wouldn't see heads cut off in this
way
not least of all because they're wearing
armor
could a sword do it yeah you could do it
if you were fighting an army of naked
people
you know the neck is one of the first
areas to
get protective equipment even if you've
got nothing else you'd have a male
collar or cough of some sort
one of the ways in which armor defends
you is
by creating curved surfaces glancing
surfaces
and of course a body is always moving as
well so you can never land a
pure 90 degree strike
you need enough edge just to bite in
order to send that energy through
and i don't believe heads fly like that
decorated swords
for honor it hungers for blood
obviously the first thing to say about
decoration it was only ever available
to the wealthy to princes
and kings but it was also much much more
restrained
than we see here
it's called a flamboyant blade because
it looks like flames
what these sharp wavy edges do
is constantly present a curved surface
to the hand
so it is impossible to grab it without
cutting your hand open even if you were
wearing a leather glove
occasionally you will find one that has
got some gilding on the cross guard
or on the pommel but you really need to
leave the blade as plain as possible
because you
don't want to compromise the integrity
of the blade
you don't want to chisel into it so that
you can put
a gold inlay you don't want to uh scroll
and etch
and pierce and punch or do anything to
it
that blade needs to perform to save your
life
leave it alone
wearing a sword on your back the witcher
3
so here we see a really familiar trope
which is
that the sword being carried on the back
in
a european medieval setting it
did not happen
the type of sword they're using here
looks similar to what we would call a
medieval long sword
which is a sword that you use with two
hands would stand
about that height
you just can't actually get it out a
sword of that length
over the shoulder swords are worn in
scabbards at the hip and outside swords
very very very long swords
are carried over the shoulder it's just
that simple
parries for honor so for this one we
actually pushed
as much as we can to cover the all the
uh
parts it all starts by getting the armor
wrong
by trying to give a sense of
of bulk and therefore presumably menace
they're amplifying the size of the armor
went to those shoulders
and making these creatures into these
great sort of
automatons who who move in a very
awkward and
lumbering way
this idea of wide swings and opening
yourself up and then you know
15 minutes later landing the blow it has
nothing to do
with reality the art of sword fighting
is constantly keeping yourself covered
they weren't lumbering slow fools
they were martial artists athletes
lightning fast reflexes who had a
system a fighting style that was
immensely sophisticated
next let's take a look at axes
throwing an axe mordow
what we see here is two types of acts
a larger axe that he's using with two
hands
he takes out a smaller axe which he uses
to throw
looking at the armor and the clothing it
looks to be more
kind of late medieval and both of those
axes shown are from a much much much
earlier medieval period from the sort of
frankish
saxon viking period the axes of the
later medieval period what known as
battle axes
were predominantly a horseman's weapon
they're not for throwing the pollacks
for honor
they carry the most versatile weapon
ever invented
the pole axe first the narrator is
calling it a polax instead of a pollax
there were such things as pole arms and
a whole
family of weapons that are that are on
long poles
but the pollacks p o double l
axe is what knights called this slightly
shorter
pole arm the pollax
was between sort of four and and five
foot in height not not a super long
pole arm it it's very much a weapon that
nights when they were fighting on foot
this was their favorite weapon
it was substantial and at the top end it
had an axe head and a hammer head
you know this was a great chunk of metal
so that could land a
fearsome bow on top of that was a spike
and most importantly at the bottom was
this
steel spike a secret of their order
the peak and it was that end that you
did
most of your fighting with and when they
arrive
pray that you one of the great
advantages of the polax is it has reach
and you can really work a close distance
at long distance
and when you get in there you can use
that
shaft as a lever
they're doing it here and that is right
that is straight out of the manuals that
you get that in there
you get it behind their legs it's the
right spirit of the thing
let's see how bows and arrows are
portrayed in video games
the crossbow mount and blade
one of the cunning things about this
clip
is they don't show you how the crossbow
is being
loaded so we have this really rather
unrealistic rate of shooting
there was a thing called a belt and claw
where a claw hung from a belt and you
went down and hooked that under the
thing and you had your
your foot in the thing and you used your
whole back to strain
and your legs and your thighs were
straining to pull that string back and
and hook it behind the trigger it
certainly couldn't be done
as quickly as in this clip
loading and aiming chivalry
there are two stages to preparing that
longbow to shoot
the first one is what we call knocking
that's the you know the little notch at
the end of the arrow and getting that
fitted to the string
in this clip the speed of getting the
arrow
onto the string was credible that that i
could shoot that fast maybe even a
little faster
[Music]
what takes longer is the second stage
the drawing back you're drawing a long
bow
from your feet to your neck every muscle
is engaged in pulling that string back
and you pull it back
here behind the ear
a longbow is a powerful weapon
180 pounds maybe even
200 pounds draw weight the amount it
takes to pull that string back
this is a massive athletic
endeavor that has to be repeated
over and over again so there are
questions of stamina
although we don't see very much of him
we can see
part of his archer's equipment which is
a leather bracer on the
inside of his left forearm and what it's
for is it's for
string slap as the string comes through
it just can
catch that arm just get a snap if you've
got a 150
180 200 pound longbow i can assure you
that string slap you never want to pull
that bow back again
flaming arrows chivalry two
so it looks great doesn't it we see
these incendiary arrows like
lightning strikes streaming across the
sky
my experience with flaming arrows is
they don't stay alight in the sky
looking quite so wonderful as that but
they do work
and they did exist does it have any
practical
military function and is it real
well you certainly wouldn't use them in
an open battlefield like that
because it's pointless what are you
going to do set individual people a
light as a bonus because you've already
killed them with your arrow you would
use them in
sieges and in terror raids
fire has always been a dreadful
awful terror weapon let's look at some
other
medieval weapons that are popular in
video games
spears mordhow
the advantage of a spear
is its reach if you've got cavalry
coming towards you
you can extend and you know you can go
for the horse the disadvantage of a
spear
is its reach there's that much of weapon
on the end of a stick once you've
extended and thrust that if the person
gets inside that point it's easy to
either
cleave your thin wooden shaft with with
their sword or their axe
or to get hold of that spear and wrench
it out of your hand
once he's inside the point the spear is
useless
mace chivalry macy's
is a general blunt force weapon were
widespread on the medieval battlefield
what we see here when they call it a
mace it's more like a morning star which
is a kind of a two-handed
mace with spikes on which came in a
little bit later
something that all armor had in common
is it deflected
blows it gave a skidding surface
it's very difficult to get that energy
into the man underneath
unless you can get a microsecond of bite
so that's really what the spikes before
they look really grisly and play into
our idea of medieval brutality
but all they're for is for grabbing hold
of the target
in order to deliver the energy through
the armor flail
for honor their flail is as dangerous to
the wielder as it is to the enemy
i mean the idea is it's the same as a
mace it's a blunt force
trauma weapon but its disadvantage is
having struck the chain goes limp and
comes down
you have to prepare it with relatively
wide
strokes we really have no
strong evidence that it was ever a real
thing we do have evidence however that
it was
thought of throughout the medieval
period military engineers and artists
and designers produced
military manuals sometimes however
you find a diamond in the rough leonardo
da vinci was one of a long line of
designers of military machines
a lot of the machines and ideas in here
never happened daggers dark
souls the dagger uses very little
stamina
so you can attack many times over before
depleting your stamina
even if you have low endurance so
daggers were pretty much a
universal weapon on the medieval
battlefield
everybody carried a dagger clearly a
weapon of
last resort it's a weapon of close
hand-to-hand fighting what i found
extraordinary
on this clip is where the narration said
do note that the range is short i just
wanted a shout on his ear
well let go of one hand and you'll
double your reach
because obviously you've got limited
reach if you're working like that but
you know i've now got double the
extension it's about
how you use what you have it's a
one-handed weapon it's not
a two-handed weapon now we're going to
talk about tactics
taking over a village kingdom come
deliverance
this clip had the the element of
surprise and you know for any attack on
a village to be successful it needs an
element of surprise
[Music]
of course if you're attacking with an
army of that
size there's not going to be any
surprise
you would hear them from miles away
you would see the clouds of dust from
miles away
so raiding parties would be small you
wouldn't need more than 20 30 men to
raid a village like that
they'd use incendiary arrows
they would gallop through with flaming
torches and drop them in the buildings
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't need a big army to attack a
small village
you do need surprise firebomb weapons
for honor did we get 12 of these bombs
like
that's it's pretty excessive different
raider
they had clay pots
which they filled with what was really
greek fire which was a secret recipe
developed in 670
or so by a man named kalinikos and this
was an incredible
flammable substance that that just kept
on burning
could even burn on water there take that
sir
but running around the battlefield with
a flammable pot is a pretty
dangerous business it's not like pulling
the pin on a grenade where you know
exactly the moment you're gonna throw it
they really
need to be deployed from a fixed
position and
best used in a ranged weapon like
festival or with a great
siege engine like a trebuchet circle
formation
mountain blade bannerlord
in certain cavalry situations
a circle formation is exactly what you
need especially
if you're outnumbered the scots called
it the children in fact they pioneered
that technique
so much i would suggest against uh an
artillery attack with an arrow storm
the bowmen only have to range slightly
differently
and they've got the backs of the people
undefended with their shields at the
other side of the circle
well it's like come and get me shoot me
in the back i wouldn't choose a circle
that size because there's so much room
in the middle you could get quite a lot
of horsemen
smashing through the line of two that
you've got there and they could wreak
havoc
round the backs of of the other troops
don't periodically keep breaking your
formation otherwise there's no
point in having it fighting on horseback
mount and blade bannerlord
cavalry can be used in two main ways you
have
heavy cavalry smashing into a massive
troops for the impact charge
and you have light cavalry with swords
or
bows or even light lance's skirmishing
or raiding or or just hurrying troops on
the battlefield
here we're seeing versatile light
cavalry
skirmishing the weapon of first strike
for the horsemen is the lance
the long lance over your back
that's the cavalry charge but it's a one
strike weapon
[Music]
it's one kebab each and you're done its
greatest benefit
is not just the speed of delivering
attacks
it's the ability to pull back and come
again
it's that ability on a horse that you
couldn't even begin to match
with a man on foot
you know the stamina of a horse to do
those
repeated attacks that's really where it
gives you the edge
let's look at defensive weapons shield
shapes mordhow today i wanted to talk
about
shields in mortal the earliest type
shown in in this clip is the kite shield
you can easily block pretty much
anything in front of you a sort of
norman style shield from the sort of
century by the 12th century it already
gone out so it has a very limited time
period to a very
specific culture the kite shield is a
much larger shield that
pretty much envelops the entire body
from head to your shins
gradually that shield gets
shorter and more compact as armor for
the lower leg gets better
and you end up with what's called the
heater shield very good for protecting
the upper torso especially when you're
on horseback
and you need that extra layer of
protection to
withstand the extraordinary
force of being struck with a lance
by a man on horseback moving on to the
perry shields we have the target the
buckler
the taj a round shield this one is
specifically a kind of scots weapon it's
it's smaller than the viking round
shield it had
you know more maneuverability rather
than just blocking with your weapon
you simply block with your shield the
highland scots were famous for their
charge
running in their kilts across the
heather you don't want something
clumsy you want something light but
they're facing arrows
that's what shields are for they're for
facing arrow storms the
buckler and the targe have very minor
differences between them but
functioning exactly the same in terms of
size they have the exact same block
radius
the type of shield that is used almost
exclusively for hand to hand fighting
is the buckler this was a specialist
little shield
round shield completely faced with steel
a little steel fist you use it
like a fist you punch the enemies
weapons away a sword's coming in here
you
punch it away very skillful but very
fast
flowing way of fighting the final shield
in mordhau is the pavice
the pavise complete polar opposite
of the buckler the pavise is a static
shield it just sits there it can be
placed down
pretty much anywhere on a flat surface
or even rough terrain
it's what crossbowman carried on their
backs
set up on the battlefield because they
had to
shelter behind something to work the
claw
mechanism of loading their bows it was a
question of different
shields for different fields but they
all had
a different purpose armor mordhow
the most important thing about armor is
that it gives you as much protection as
possible
the second most important thing about
armor is that it allows you to
fight as well as possible
what i love about this clip is that it
starts with a knight
running whilst wearing armor
that is a reality a knight would be able
to run to sprint in
armor boosika one of the generals of the
french army at agincourt
he was known to go for a mile run in his
armor every morning
the dropkick is probably a little bit
fantastical but
armor was designed for the fighting man
the way we see a sword slicing through
armour that's just
plain fantasy it's fine as fantasy but
it's certainly not
a reality so there's a lot of different
types of armor
plate armor the type we're seeing here a
second skin
of metal an exoskeleton of metal
where the night became a walking work of
art and it was
tailored to precision
so that every joint articulated
the most vulnerable points are those
articulation points so
if you're raising your sword to strike
then that is more vulnerable than the
bit covered with a plate
but they had things called bezejews
which which are little metal disks they
have
solutions to these problems
so there is this constant trade-off
between
weight articulation and protection
[Music]
that has been extremely interesting to
me as a dull old historian to
look at how these weapons are
represented in video games
what's exciting about video games today
is it's often the first hook
the first lure to get young minds
interested in history and history is
exciting
and we mustn't lose the excitement just
because of a few
details that might not be right